um
foreign
foreign
oh
uh
uh
um
give me
good afternoon folks let me begin by
saying that uh
the degree of cooperation
between local state and federal
officials down here has been
remarkable i want to thank our fema
director
for leading this national effort but
governor desantis
senators rubio and scott
congressman debbie wasserman schultz and
the
mayor gaba kava they've been
they've all cooperated in ways that i
haven't seen in a long time
and it's really a testament to uh
towards how difficult things are down
here and
it's what uh quite frankly we miss a lot
you know we we've all been working in
tandem
from the moment we got the news of the
collapse of the building
and i think my colleagues will tell you
we cut through the bureaucracy the one
the one order i gave the federal folks
was
no bureaucracy just cut through it get
to whatever they need
that's why we decided to cover for
example 100
of the search and rescue cost for the
first 30 days
not done often but necessary here in my
view
and fema is going to provide temporary
housing
and other urgent needs for the survivors
state department is expediting visas for
family members
from other countries and there are from
latin america south america
europe israel and i want to give a
special shout out
to first responders the international
association of firefighters
one of the best organizations in the
country and i particularly
want to thank the president ed came down
from boston
and he's here with the entire the entire
group
you know these folks are these folks are
always showing up
no matter what they're risking their
lives
you know there's that old expression i
know the press that travels with me is
tired hearing me saying but i'm not
tired of saying it
and that is that old expression god made
man then he made a few firefighters
the remarkable remarkable people there's
always uh they're always risking their
lives to save lives as well as
the police and other first responders i
got to meet with a whole bunch of them
and we're able to deploy nearly 500
personnel
including five other search and rescue
teams on the ground today here because
of our freeman director
ordered it i want to compliment fema and
i might add
all those folks are risking their lives
to save lives
but also holding out hope for those will
be found
hope springs eternal when i talked to
those first responders
i pointed out that they're under a great
deal of stress
and we should take advantage they should
take advantage
of the mental health facilities that are
going to be available because
you know we talk about our military
suffering from post-traumatic stress
well seeing what they're seeing doing
what they're doing understanding how
how much trauma is involved
i just don't want them thinking that
they should walk away from help if it's
needed
you know they stand together and it's
really impressive
and there's also the need in addition to
state and local assistance to determine
the cause of this collapse and
the adjacent buildings how safe they are
there are two outstanding concerns
first remaining buildings may collapse
the remainder of the building may
collapse
we need to determine if it's safe for
first responders to return to the site
to continue their rescue mission
that's being done right now and that's
why i asked the national institute of
standards and technology
nissa to investigate to see if it's safe
to go back
and what caused the building to collapse
in the first place
because we're committed not only to
recover but to restore
the safety across the board but the
other reason i came down
was to meet with the families the whole
nation is borning with these families
they see it every day on television
they're going through hell
and those who survive the collapse as
well as those
who are missing loved ones i realize i'm
a little late because i spent a lot of
time with the families
a whole lot of time and i apologize for
taking so long to get here because i
thought it was important to speak to
every single person
who wanted to speak to me so after
what you all covered when i opened up
the the
the meeting i spent the remainder of the
time
and i and such incredible people
i sat with one woman who had just uh
lost her her husband and her little baby
boy
didn't know what to do i sat with
another family that lost
almost an entire family cousins brothers
sisters
and to watch them and the the they're
praying and pleading that god
that to be a miracle let there be
something happen for me that's good
because i have like many of you do some
idea what it's like to suffer that kind
of loss
so many of them are suffering you know
they had basic heart-wrenching questions
will i be able to recover the body of my
son or daughter my husband
my cousin my mom and dad
how can i have closure without being
able to bury them if i don't get the
body what do i do
jill and i want them to know that we're
with them
and the country's with them our message
today is that we're
here for you as one nation
as one nation and that's the message we
communicated
we'll be in touch with a lot of these
families continuing through this process
but there is much more to be done we're
ready to do it
and again i thank the governor i thank
my
colleagues my senator scott
senator rubio i thank debbie wasserman
schultz
for their total complete cooperation
there's no there's no disagreement no
bickering
everybody's in the same team it's what
america is all about
it's about pulling together leaving
nobody behind
and that's what made me feel the one
thing made me feel good about this
is the is a cohesion that exists there's
no democrat or republican out there
they're just people wanting to do the
right thing for their fellow americans
so thank god bless the victims and their
families
and god protect our first responders
and i'll take a couple questions right
now
what were you told today about the
likelihood you said hope springs eternal
but that
somebody will be able to be pulled out
alive from this and what were you able
to convey to the families
uh about that possibility
well look um first of all
the families are very realistic they
know the longer it goes
and one of the things that the
that the local fema personnel as well as
the local first responders did they took
all of the
families to the site to see
to see what it looked like up close and
they're all realist they all look and
they see those floors just literally
feet cement upon cement upon a cement
you know i uh when i talked to some of
the families
some some of the people who did escape
they survived got out
they talked about watching the building
collapse and watching as they're in the
garage
one floor come down literally on the
whole floor on top of another floor
they know that the chances are as east
day goes by it diminished slightly
but at a minimum at a minimum they want
to recover the bodies
they want to recover the bodies there's
a lot of very religious people
who are in there members of the rabbis
in the jewish community were talking
about the need to make sure that they
recover the body and be able to bury
them
give them and you know
anyway so i think they're very realistic
mike
um but but i don't think that that in
any way suggests that it's
too uh as we should stop
i think that we should move on continue
to try to recover the bodies
in the meantime that's why nist and
others are determining whether or not
it's safe
to send the first responders back when
they'd asked me about this i'd point out
that the last thing they would want and
we would want
is in the process of trying to recover
and the possibility there's still a
possibility
someone could be alive someone could
still be breathing someone could be
there
that the last thing you want to have
happen is have that building collapse
and kill 10 20 30 50 firefighters
or wound them or first responders
so uh but mike they're you know they're
realistic i
it just brought back so many
so many memories it's bad enough
it's bad enough to lose somebody
but the hard part the really hard part
is to not know whether they're surviving
or not
just not having the idea
when the accident took my wife my family
the hardest part was
were my boys going to get out because
they're going to make it
um did not know it not knowing when
you're flying home from washington to
get the news you know i just don't know
so it's uh but i was amazed
as you know unfortunately
i've done a lot of these circumstances
where i've met with families who have
had great laws
and what amazed me about this group of
people
was their resilience their absolute
commitment their willingness to do
whatever it took
to find uh to find an
answer i i walked away
impressed uh by their strength
and uh um nancy bloomberg do you have a
question
i was told oh thank you um yeah what did
you learn if anything about the collapse
of the building is there anything more
you learn from investigators or the fema
administration no it's underway
i don't uh the director of fema is with
me here we don't have any
firm proof of what's happened there's
all kinds of uh
rational speculation about whether or
not
the rebars are rusted whether or not the
cement
uh whether it's limestone or not whether
or not
but a lot of the a lot of families who
survived
talked about how upset they were that
in the last years that they've been here
how
there was one condominium complex built
across
the street and a road was purchased and
while they were living there they would
hear the drilling
and they'd feel their building moving
and shaking
uh there are all kinds of discussions
about whether or not
um they uh they thought that water level
rising what impact it had
and interesting to me i didn't raise it
but how many of the survivors and how
many of the families talked about
the impact of global warming how much it
and did they know exactly but they
talked about sea levels rising and about
how how and and the
combination of that and the concern
about incoming
storms incoming tropical storms and so
but i don't think there is at this point
any definitive
judgment as to why it collapsed and
what can be done to prevent it from
happening and what other buildings may
have to be
inspected to determine if they have the
same problems
i'm supposed to head out and catch up
with the governor
so i want to thank you all for taking
the time
away from where we are now first is
while you've been speaking
a top associate of the former president
has been in a new york court
um pleading not guilty to various
financial charges do you have a reaction
to that and and secondarily if i can
does the supreme court's ruling today on
an important voting rights decision add
to the sense of urgency you feel
about pursuing voting rights legislation
at this time
i know nothing about the first
circumstance because i've been gone i
don't have any ideas so i'm not going to
come into that and
even if i did i wouldn't comment on an
ongoing case if it's an ongoing case
with regard to the second point i think
i did
get a summary on the way down on the
plane of the supreme court decision
it is mildly positive in the sense that
there's a remedy
available based on the particular voting
decision
i think that it is critical
that we make a distinction
between voter suppression
and suspension the ability of a state
legislative body to come along
and vote their legislature vote to
change who
is declared the winner i find to be
somewhat astounding but the supreme
court
rule did not rule that way today the
best of my knowledge
and but i'll have much more to say about
that because i plan on
speaking extensively on floating rights
and as well as
going on the road on this issue thank
you all very much
you